Comme quoi, faire plusieurs choses à la fois peut avoir du bon !
Bon, travailler simultanément
sur le mouvement brownien, la relativité générale et l'effet photoélectrique,
ce n'est pas exactement du même registre que
de jongler entre Snapchat et sa série préférée sur HBO.
C'est même très différent.
Et surtout, Einstein... C'est Einstein :
il est unique en son genre.
Mais le comportement qu'Einstein avait adopté, lui,
est loin d'être unique.
C'est la caractéristique des personnes très créatives,
artistes et scientifiques.
Et j'aimerais lui donner un nom :
le multitâche au ralenti.
Bien que ça ait l'air un peu contradictoire.
Ce que je décris,
c'est le fait d'avoir plusieurs projets sur le feu au même moment,
et de passer de l'un à l'autre en fonction de nos humeurs,
ou de la situation qui se présente.
Mais si ça a l'air contradictoire,
c'est parce que c'est le désespoir qui nous pousse habituellement au multitâche.
On est pressé, on veut tout faire en même temps.
En ralentissant le rythme,
on peut voir que ça marche plutôt bien !
Il y a soixante ans, une jeune psychologue du nom de Bernice Eiduson
a commencé un long travail de recherche
sur la personnalité et les habitudes de travail
de 40 scientifiques de renom.
Einstein était déjà mort,
mais quatre de ses sujets d'étude ont gagné des prix Nobel,
dont Linus Pauling et Richard Feynman.
La recherche a pris des décennies,
elle a continué après la mort du professeur Eiduson.
Et une des réponses auxquelles elle a répondu était :
« Comment les scientifiques sont capables de fournir une telle quantité de travail
tout au long de leur vie ? »
Qu'ont-ils de particulier ?
Est-ce leur personnalité ? Leurs compétences ?
Leurs routines journalières ?
Eh bien, une tendance s'est dégagée et en a surpris plus d'un.
Les grands scientifiques n'ont fait que passer d'un sujet à l'autre.
Et ils l'ont fait de manière répétée
pendant leurs 100 premières publications de recherches scientifiques.
Et vous savez à quelle fréquence ?
Trois fois ?
Cinq fois ?
Non. En moyenne, les scientifiques les plus durablement créatifs
ont changé 43 fois de sujet au cours de leurs 100 premières publications.
C'est donc ça, le secret de la créativité :
le multitâche au ralenti.
Les recherches d'Eiduson proposent une repopularisation du multitâche
et d'un rappel d'à quel point il peut être puissant.
Et elle n'est pas la seule à l'avoir découvert.
Différents chercheurs,
utilisant différentes méthodes d'étude sur les personnes très créatives,
ont trouvé qu'elles avaient souvent plusieurs sujets en cours
au même moment,
et qu'elles étaient plus aptes que nous à avoir des passe-temps sérieux.
Le multitâche au ralenti est omniprésent chez les personnes créatives.
Mais pourquoi ?
Selon moi, il y a trois raisons.
La première est la plus simple.
La créativité survient souvent en sortant une idée de son contexte original
et en la déplaçant autre part.
Sortir des sentiers battus,
c'est plus simple en passant d'un chemin à l'autre.
Prenez par exemple l'origine du fameux « eurêka ! ».
Archimède essayait de résoudre un problème difficile.
Quand soudain, il réalise
qu'il peut le résoudre en utilisant le déplacement de l'eau.
Si on en croit la légende,
l'idée lui est venue quand il prenait son bain,
se plongeant dedans, et observant le niveau de l'eau monter et baisser.
Et si résoudre un problème dans son bain n'est pas une preuve de multitâche,
alors je ne sais plus rien !
La seconde raison du succès du multitâche,
c'est qu'apprendre à faire une chose correctement
aide souvent à en faire une autre.
Tout athlète vous confirmera les bénéfices du cross-training.
Il est tout autant possible d'entraîner son cerveau.
Il y a quelques années, les chercheurs ont pris 18 étudiants en médecine au hasard
et les ont inscrits à un cours au Musée d'Art de Philadelphie,
où ils ont appris à critiquer et analyser des œuvres d'art.
A la fin de ce cursus,
les étudiants ont été comparés avec un autre groupe
de leurs collègues de médecine.
Ceux ayant suivi le cours d'art
étaient devenus plus performants dans des tâches
telles que le diagnostic de maladies de l'œil par l'analyse de photos.
Ils sont devenus de meilleurs ophtalmologistes.
Donc, pour devenir plus performant,
il faudrait peut-être faire quelque chose d'autre,
même dans un domaine tout à fait différent de celui de base,
comme l'ophtalmologie et l'art.
Et si vous en voulez plus d'exemples,
prenons en un moins intimidant que celui d'Einstein.
Prenons Michael Crichton, créateur de « Jurassic Park » et « Urgences ».
Dans les années 70, il a reçu une formation de médecin,
puis il a écrit des romans,
puis dirigé le film original « Westworld ».
Mais aussi, et ça on le sait moins,
il a écrit des livres de référence
sur l'art, la médecine, sur la programmation informatique.
En 1995, il a récolté les fruits de toute cette diversité
en pondant le livre au plus gros succès commercial du monde,
la série au plus gros succès commercial du monde
et le film au plus gros succès commercial du monde.
Ce qu'il a réitéré en 1996.
Il y a une troisième raison
qui fait que le multitâche au ralenti peut nous aider à résoudre nos problèmes.
Il peut nous fournir de l'aide quand on n'arrive plus à avancer.
Ça peut arriver n'importe quand.
Imaginez que vous faites des mots croisés,
que vous ne trouvez pas un mot,
parce que vous avez un autre mot en tête.
La solution est simple : faites autre chose.
Changez de sujet, de contexte.
Vous oublierez ce mot,
et vous aurez enfin de la place en tête pour la bonne réponse.
Mais à plus une petite échelle, qui m'intéresse,
être bloqué est une chose plus sérieuse.
On vous refuse un prêt.
Votre culture de cellules ne grandit pas. Vos fusées s'écrasent.
Personne ne veut publier votre roman fantastique sur une école de sorciers.
Ou bien, vous ne trouvez pas la solution à votre problème.
Ce genre de blocage provoque de la congestion, du stress,
peut-être même de la dépression.
Mais si vous avez un autre projet palpitant sur lequel travailler,
votre blocage vous permet justement de vous concentrer sur cet autre projet.
Tout le monde peut rencontrer ce problème, même Albert Einstein.
Dix ans après cette année spectaculaire que j'ai décrite tantôt,
Einstein rassemblait ses éléments sur la théorie de la relativité générale.
Sa plus grande réussite.
Et il en était épuisé.
Il s'est alors tourné vers un problème plus simple.
Il a exposé l'émission stimulée de rayonnement.
Ce qui correspond au « S » de « laser ».
Il pose donc les fondements théoriques du faisceau laser,
et, en parallèle,
il revient sur la relativité générale. Et il a les idées au clair.
Il voit ce que la théorie implique :
que l'univers n'est pas figé.
Il est en expansion.
C'est une idée si stupéfiante
qu'Einstein lui-même met des années avant d'y croire.
Si jamais vous êtes coincé,
et que vous êtes essayez de poser les bases du rayon laser,
vous êtes en bon chemin !
(Rires)
C'est en tout cas le cas pour les multitâches au ralenti !
Et je ne vous promets pas que vous en deviendrez des Einstein.
Ni des Michael Crichton, d'ailleurs.
Mais c'est une bonne manière d'organiser nos vies créatives !
Il y a cependant un problème.
Comment mettre en pause tous ces projets qui nous surmènent ?
Comment garder toutes ces idées en tête ?
Eh bien, voilà une solution simple et pratique
offerte par la grande chorégraphe américaine Twyla Tharp.
Ces quelques dernières décennies,
elle a dépassé les limites, mélangé les genres, gagné des prix.
dansé sur des musiques allant de Philip Glass à Billy Joel.
Elle a écrit trois livres.
Et bien sûr, elle est adepte du multitâche au ralenti.
Elle dit : « Vous devez être tout.
Pourquoi se mettre des barrières ?
Soyez tout. »
Et sa méthode
pour éviter que tous ces projets différents ne la surpassent
est assez simple.
Chacun de ses projets a sa boîte en carton
sur laquelle elle écrit le nom du projet.
Elle y met des DVD, des livres, des pages de magazines,
des programmes de théâtres, des objets,
à peu près tout ce qui lui serait une source d'inspiration créative.
Et elle écrit :
« La boîte me garantit de ne jamais oublier.
La plus grande peur pour une personne créative
est de perdre une idée géniale
parce qu'elle n'a pas pu la noter et la ranger à un endroit sûr.
Je n'ai pas ce problème-là,
parce que je sais où la retrouver.
Dans sa boîte. »
Vous pouvez gérer beaucoup d'idées ainsi,
soit dans de vraies boîtes, ou dans leurs équivalents virtuels.
Je vous encourage donc
à adopter cette technique du multitâche au ralenti.
Non pas parce que vous êtes pressés.
Mais justement parce que vous ne l'êtes pas.
Je veux vous donner un dernier exemple,
mon préféré.
Charles Darwin.
Une personne avec méthode si stupéfiante
qu'il me faut un diagramme pour vous l'expliquer
On a pu retracer ce que Darwin faisait et quand,
grâce aux inventifs chercheurs Howard Gruber et Sara Davis
et à leurs analyses de ses journaux et de ses cahiers.
Quand il a quitté l'école à 18 ans,
Darwin s'est intéressé à deux domaines :
la zoologie et la géologie.
Très vite, il s'inscrit comme naturaliste à bord du Beagle -
le bateau sur lequel il a passé cinq ans
à naviguer sur les océans du sud,
s'arrêtant aux Galapagos, traversant l'Océan indien.
Sur le Beagle, il a commencé à étudier les récifs coralliens.
Un juste milieu parfait entre ses deux centres d'intérêts,
la zoologie et la géologie.
Et il commence à réfléchir aux processus lents.
Mais en revenant de ce voyage,
ses intérêts continuent de s'étendre : à la psychologie, la botanique...
Il passe le reste de sa vie
à jongler entre ces différents domaines.
Il n'en oublie jamais vraiment aucun d'entre eux.
En 1837, il commence à travailler sur deux projets très intéressants.
D'abord : les vers de terre.
Ensuite : il écrit un petit carnet
sur « La Transmutation des espèces ».
Puis, Darwin s'intéresse à mon domaine, l'économie.
Il lit un livre de l'économiste Thomas Malthus.
Et, eurêka !
Il réalise que les espèces peuvent émerger et évoluer lentement
par la fameuse « loi du plus fort ».
Tout lui vient à l'esprit, il écrit tout,
chaque élément important de sa théorie de l'évolution,
dans ce petit carnet.
Mais un nouveau projet se présente :
son fils William naît.
Devant ses yeux, il a une expérience naturelle,
la chance d'observer le développement d'un bébé humain.
Tout de suite, il commence à prendre des notes.
Il travaille bien sûr encore sur la théorie de l'évolution,
avec en parallèle celle sur le développement d'un enfant.
Mais avec tout ça,
il réalise qu'il ne sait pas grand-chose sur la taxonomie.
Il commence donc à l'étudier,
et il finit, huit ans après, par devenir l'expert mondial
des balanes.
Puis, « La Sélection naturelle »,
un livre jamais terminé sur lequel il a travaillé toute sa vie.
« L'origine des Espèces » est finalement publié
20 ans après que Darwin en avait posé les premières bases.
Puis, « La Filiation de l'Homme », un livre controversé.
Et après, le livre sur le développement de l'enfant humain -
basé sur ce qu'il a observé de son fils William,
rampant sur le sol du salon.
Ce livre a été publié quand William avait 37 ans.
Durant tout ce temps,
Darwin étudie les vers de terre.
Il remplit sa salle de billard de vers de terre dans des pots en verre.
Il les éclaire, et observe leur réaction.
Il approche un tisonnier chaud, et observe s'ils s'éloignent.
Il mâche du tabac
(Souffle)
et souffle en leur direction pour voir s'ils ont un odorat.
Il leur joue même du basson !
J'aime imaginer ce grand homme,
fatigué, stressé,
et anxieux sur ce que les gens penseront de son livre « La Filiation de l'Homme ».
Vous ou moi, nous allons sur Facebook ou allumons notre télévision.
Darwin, lui, allait se détendre dans sa salle de billard,
en étudiant avec passion ses vers de terre.
Il est donc logique que son dernier grand travail fut
« La Formation de la terre végétale par l'action des vers de terre ».
(Rires)
Il a travaillé 44 ans sur ce livre.
Alors, nous ne vivons plus au 19e siècle.
Aucun de nous ne pourrait passer
44 ans sur ses projets scientifiques ou créatifs.
Mais il nous reste un héritage de ces experts du multitâches au ralenti.
D'Einstein à Darwin, en passant par Michael Crichton et Twyla Tharp...
Le monde moderne semble nous poser un dilemme :
si nous ne passons pas notre temps à surfer sur internet,
nous devrions être des ermites,
concentrés sur une chose et excluant tout le reste.
Et je pense que c'est un faux dilemme.
Nous pouvons adopter le multitâche,
et libérer notre créativité naturelle.
Nous devons juste ralentir.
Donc...
Faites une liste de vos projets.
Rangez votre téléphone.
Prenez quelques boîtes en carton.
Mettez-vous au travail !
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)